So, we're going to be starting Chapter 6. Chapter 6 is made up of two parts of Part
A and Part B, and this is on bones and skeletal tissue. So, we all start off as skeletal cartonge.
So, human skeleton initially is made up just of cartilage. So, when you're talking, when
you're looking at a fetus and then a baby and infant, there is cartilage that's present,
mostly cartilage. As an organism grows, as the baby grows, the cartilage gets replaced
by bone. Now, the place is that it's not replaced by compact bone, by hard bone, is
areas that require flexibility. That will stay as cartilage.
Now, skeletal cartilage is made up of highly resilient, molded cartilage tissue. That's
mostly water, and this water is what gives it its resiliency. It doesn't contain any
blood vessels or nerves. Now, how this cartilage gets this nourishment form is from the pericardium.
The pericardium is what contains blood vessels. So, nutrients are able to be delivered to
the cartilage tissue. So, what is a pericardium, exactly? It's a little dense, connective
tissue that surrounds the cartilage, and it acts like a bridal. It helps the cartilage
resist its outward expansion, so it creates its boundaries. Cartilage is made up of
chondrocytes, if you guys recall, back from chapter 4. And these are cells that are encased
within these cavities that are called the lacunae, and then they have an extracellular
matrix that's it's jelly-like. So, we have three types of cartilage in our body. High
lean, elastic, and fiber cartilage. So, again, this is a bit of a recap from chapter 4. Highly
cartilage recalls that it provides support, flexibility, and resilience, and it's the
most abundant type of cartilage. It's made up of collagen fibers only when we find them
at our joints, at ribs. It's what connects the ribs to your sternum. It makes up your
larynx, and also makes up the tip of your nose. Elastic cartilage, it's similar to
highly cartilage, but it contains elastic fibers. And we find this only in two places
in the body. It makes up the epiglitis, and it makes up the upper part of your ear. The
last type of fiber cartilage, it's made up of thick collagen fibers, and it offers great
tensile strength. And it has, remember, one of the things that it does is it absorbs compression
and shock. So, we find this at the miniscuy of our knees, and also we find that in between
our back ones, your vertebraes, to form the vertebral discs. So, when you look over here,
this is showing you that here you have cartilage in your nose. You have articulate cartilage
over here, over here as well, your cussel cartilage. So, this is all hyaline cartilage
over here, over here, again, over here. It's lining both the, this is the head of the femur,
and then also the head of the humerus. You have in between your bones over here, in your
carples, your wrist bones. Now, let's look at fiber cartilage. So, fiber cartilage, again,
you see them over here, between your back bones, so they make up the intravertebral discs,
then also they're there between your knee. So, it's part of your knee joint. In addition
to that, you also have at the pubic synthesis over here. This is what connects the front
part of your two hip bones together. It lasts your cartilage. Remember what we said, it's
only a couple of, a couple of places that we find it, and they're showing one of the
places over here. It lasts your cartilage, they're showing that, you know, you'll have
it on your, the upper part of your ear over here. This is signifying. And over here, you
can see the larynx. Yeah, the larynx over here is showing you, and when you see your larynx,
as well as your trachea, it's all made up of hyaline cartilage. But the extraction is
the epiglitis. The epiglitis is made up of the elastic cartilage. So, how does cartilage
grow? Cartilage grows in two ways. Apositional growth and interstitial growth. And we're going
to be looking at both of these things in detail. So, in apositional growth, the cartilage forming
cells, in the pericondion, they secrete the matrix against the external face of the existing
cartilage. So, the new matrix ends up getting laid down on the surface of the cartilage.
In interstitial growth, the chondrocytes within the lacunae, they divide and they're secreting
new matrix that expands, that's expanding the cartilage from within. So, the new matrix
is made within the cartilage. Now, calcification of cartilage occurs during normal bone growth
in youth, but it can also happen in older, in older age, also in the line, near the line.
This heartened cartilage, it's not the same as bone, it's different. So, there are seven
important functions of bone. And we discussed some of these in chapter four. So, first of all,
bone is there for support, okay? It's there for your body, it's supporting some of your
soft organs, for example, they anchor onto the bones, it's there for protection. So, when you look
at the bones, it's protecting the brain, it's protecting the spinal cord and other organs,
vital organs, like your lungs and heart, it's being protected by your rib cage.
It also acts as levers, okay, for muscles to attach to and move. And it's because of bones and
muscles, you know, some of the muscles are contracting, they pull these bones and we're able to move.
Mineral and growth factor, factor storage. This is where calcium, phosphorus, and other salts are
stored in your body, it acts as a storage reserve. So, and if you think about it, now these
important, these minerals that you find, they're very important for, for normal health. And also,
for example, at times of illness, when you're sick, when you have a cold or another infection,
your body starts breaking down the bones to release these salts. So, when you think about it,
you know, when you're sick and, you know, your mother or your grandmother told you to drink
chicken soup, the reason you're, you know, the chicken soup is good for you is, again, when you
boil the bones, when you're boiling the chicken, you know, it's the bones that you're boiling,
where all the nutrition is coming from, to help you feel better. So, yes, that's why you boil the
bone and the chicken is to release the stored minerals that are found in it. Blood cell formation
to the process of hematopoises. Okay, so when you've got hemat is blood, okay,
poises or, you know, making producing. So, blood gets produced in red bone marrow. Okay, so when
you look at bone, you're going to find that it's, you have red bone marrow and yellow bone marrow.
The yellow bone marrow, this is where this a fat is stored. Okay, triglycerides are stored.
The red bone marrow, this is where blood is produced within the bone. Also, hormone production.
So, osteocalcin secreted by bones, it helps regulate insulin secretion. So, insulin secretion,
what it does in return is it maintains your blood sugar levels, your glucose levels, and metabolism.
Now, in an adult, there are 206 bones that are named in the adult, in 206 bones. Now, can anybody
guess how many bones you find in a child? If you guessed it, a child has, a baby when he's born,
has 300 bones in his body, 300. And as the baby grows, those bones start to fuse together until
there's ultimately 206 bones left. Now, your skeletal system is divided into two groups based
on the location. We end up getting an axial skeletal system and appendicular skeletal system.
Axial skeleton, again, it's just everything that's on the long axis of the body.
So, your skull, your back bones, that's called your vertebral column and your rib cage,
this is part of your axial skeleton. Everything else, we're talking about all your limbs
and your hip bones, that's part of your appendicular skeleton.
So, when you look over here, everything that you see that's in this color over here,
this dark tan color, that's all your axial skeleton. So, again, you have all your back bones,
your ribs over here, your skull, again, this is all part of your, and then also your sternum,
your breast bone over here, that's all part of your axial skeleton. Everything else, your arms,
your clavicles, your scapula, your hip bones, and then the bones that make up your leg,
these are all part of your appendicular skeleton. Now, bones, they are classified according to
shapes as well. So, now, there's four shapes. Some bones are long, if the bones are much longer
than they are in width, we call them long bones. So, most of the bones that make up your limbs
are examples of long bones. Now, short bones, these bones, they're cube-shaped bones, okay? So,
the bones that make up your, that you find in your wrist and your ankles, these are short bones.
The sesomide bones, they form within tendons. So, example would be the patella, this is sesomide
bone, and they vary in size and in a number in different individuals. You have the idiosyncratic
variations for the sesomide bone bones. Flat bones, flat bones, they're thin, they're flat,
and they could be slightly curved. So, examples of flat bones are sternum, scapula, and your ribs,
and most of the bones that make up the skull are also flat bones. Then, you have irregular bones,
irregular bones, complicated shapes. They don't fit into any one of the carryable gorys that we
previously described. So, your back bones and your hip bones are examples of irregular bones.
So, when you look over here, this is a long bone. Notice that it's much, much longer than it is in
width. So, perfect example of a long bone. Now, when you look at this bone over here,
this is a short bone because it's almost a cube-shaped. The bones in your wrist,
they're also examples of short bones. Remember, this is a sesomide bone, this example of a sesomide
bone, this patella, or your kneecap. Again, another long bone here, another long bone, long bone,
and then you have your irregular bone, and your back bones are irregular. They have some really
thin presses also at the same time, or flat, as you call them. But then, at the same time,
you know, they're not long either. So, again, this is called an irregular. It has, it doesn't
fall into any one, a single one of these categories, of the definitions of the previous categories
that we described. Flat bones, also, these are just, again, they're flat, they're slightly curved
bones. But the key thing is that they're flat, they're thin. So, the bones that make up your skull
as all, as another example of these flat bones. So, bones, they're an organ because they contain
different types of tissue. Okay. So, by definition, again, what did we say? Tissue two or more
different type of tissues. When they come together, they form an organ. So, in the previous chapter
and then skin, when you had epithelial tissue and the connective tissue, the epithelial tissue that
made up your epidermis and the connective tissue that made up your dermis, when it came together,
it formed your chitaneous membrane. Okay. It made up your skin. Another term for bones,
again, that you'll see used interchangeably is aci. So, when you see the word aci, aci is,
it means pertaining to bone. So, aci is tissue, bone tissue is predominant. But a bone also has
nervous tissue that you find within it. Okay. There's cartilage, fibrous connective tissue,
muscle cells, epithelial cells in the blood vessels that are present also within the bone.
So, there's three levels of structure that you can look at. When you're looking at bones,
there is the gross level of structure. There's a microscopic and then there's also the chemical.
So, at the gross level, we're looking at compact bone and spongy bone. So, compact bone, this is
the dense outer layer of every bone. Okay. And this is what looks smooth and it's very solid.
Spongy bone. Now, this is the inner parts of the bone and it's mostly not always, but it's the
inner part of the bone. It's made up of honeycombs of small needle-like or flat pieces of bone that's
called the trabecula. The open spaces between the trabecula, they're filled with red or a yellow
bone marrow. Now, structures of short irregular and flat bones, they're made up of thin plates
of spongy bone, okay, that we refer to as the dipole. They're covered on the external, on the
outside, they're covered by compact bones. Compact bones, this sandwich between connective tissue
membranes, okay, and then you have this periosteum that covers the outside of the compact bone
and the endosteum, which covers the inside of the compact bone. So, remember, periosteum,
endosteum, endomens within, peri means around, okay, surrounding covering. So, this is the covering
that's on the outside of the bone and this is the inside covering. So, bone marrow is scattered
throughout your spongy bone. There's no defined marrow cavities. Hiling cartilage, it covers areas
of the bone. That's part of a movable joint. So, wherever bone is about to connect or come into
contact with another bone, you're going to have cartilage over there. Hiling cartilage at that point.
So, again, if you look over here, this is the compact bone, okay, the hard part, and this is the
spongy bone, okay, this is the soft bone. And these holes, these are the trabeculae that you see over
here, okay, these parts that you see over here make up the holes are the trabeculae. So, again,
you can see over here on the trabeculae of the spongy bones right over here.
So, the structure of a typical long bone. So, long bone, all long bones, they have a shaft. The
shaft is called a diaphysis, okay, diaphysis. Now, the ends are called the epiphysis, okay,
and there's also a membranes that are present. Now, the diaphysis is a tubular shaft that forms a
long axis of a bone, and it's made up of compact bone that's run by a central medullary cavity,
and that central cavity, the central canal, that's for the yellow marrow in adults. Now,
the epiphysis, these are the ends of the bones, okay, the ends of the long bones, and they're made
up of a compact bone externally, and on the inside you have spongy bone internally. The
articular cartilages, they cover the surfaces of the these epiphysis, at the ends of these joints.
Now, between the diaphysis and the epiphysis, there is what's referred to as an FSCO line, or
it's what's left over of an FSCO plate. So, this is where bone was growing. There was cartilage over
here, between these two bones. As a child grows, okay, what happens is the cartilage, it starts to,
you know, disappear, or not disappear, but the cartilage gets replaced by bone slowly,
and this is what how bones grow from, you know, from birth to adulthood. So, when you look over here,
now, this is the ends of the bones, and at the ends of the bone, you have this articular cartilage
here that you have here, because remember, this part of the bone is going to touch another bone,
this part of the bone is also going to touch another bone. You cannot have two bones touching
each other. When you have two bones touching each other and they rub against each other,
both those bones are going to end up getting worn out, and then, you know, you have to have
surgery and you need to get bone replacement. That's essentially what ends up happening with
knee replacement surgery. So, in arthritis, this is what ends up happening in the lab, but most of
the time, again, if you're not able to get it treated or, you know, you don't take further
precautions, eventually, the cartilage gets worn away, and then the bones start rubbing against
each other, and it's excruciatingly painful. So, again, remember, the end of the bone is the
epiphysis. Now, this part is closer to the trunk, so it's the proximal epiphysis. Now, this is the
humerus, by the way. This is your upper arm bone, this bone right here. So, this is part that connects
into your shoulder, and this is the part that connects with your lower arm, your forearm.
So, the proximal epiphysis is up over here, and this is the distal epiph, or distal epiphysis.
The middle is the diaphysis. Now, notice, this is the outer bone. This is the compact bone,
and this is all the spongy bone. Right here, this is the FSCO line, right over here, FSCO line.
Now, if you take an X-ray and you see that in an X-ray, you can tell both of these,
you know, this bone is solid, if it's connected, then you know that, you know, those individuals
are not going to grow anymore. They've reached their limit. In a child, you're not going to see
that, you know, there's going to be a gap you'll see, you'll notice, because there's cartridge
there. So, when you look at an X-ray, it's going to, the parent's going to be different.
So, yeah, this is the medullary cavity, so this is where you're going to have yellow bone marrow
over here. And remember, this inner part is lined with the endosteum. This is where the endosteum is
found. The periosteum, you're going to find covering, the outer part of the bone, the compact bone.
The periosteum is over here, and that's going to be found over here, within.
So, again, this is a close-up that's showing you. This is the compact bone over here,
the hard part of the bone. The articular cartilage is over here. It's lining the end of this bone.
Spongy bone you're going to find inside. Notice you have the blood vessels that are penetrating
this bone throughout the trabeculae, the spongy bone.
Now, as far as membrane goes, so the two membranes we discussed earlier, the periosteum and endosteum.
The periosteum, it's white, it's a double-glared membrane that externally covers the surface,
except at the joints. So, it's made up of a fibrous layer, and this is the outer layer,
that's made up of dense irregular connective tissue. And it's made up of these sharpies fibres
that secure to the bone matrix. Then there's an austereogenic layer. And this is the inner layer,
that's abutting the bone, and it contains these osteogenic stem cells that gives rise to most
of all the bone cells. So, in other words, these are the cells that are going to make the bone,
making cells, osteogenic stem cells, they produce bone. So, the periosteum, it contains many nerve
fibers and blood vessels that continue on to the shaft through these little holes that we have
within the bones, that are called the neutrete foramen. Foramen, they're tiny openings, small holes,
tiny openings. It also provides angry points for tendons and ligaments to attach to you.
So, you can see that this is a very important membrane. Now, the endosteum, this is the inner
part, remember, it's a delicate connective tissue membrane that's covering the internal bone surface,
and it covers a trabeculae of spongy bones as well. It lines the canals that pass through the
compact bone. So, like the periosteum, it also contains bone-forming cells, these osteogenic cells,
and these cells, they will differentiate to other type of bone cells.
So, again, it's the same thing. You're looking at the endosteum here. This is yellow bone marrow
over here. This is compact bone. This is the periosteum, and these holes that you see here,
these are the neutrete foramen that we talked about. So, these are tiny openings, and this is a
nutrient artery. Now, we call it "nurishing" because it's nourishing the bone. And over here,
you can see these fibers. These are these sharpie fibers that we were talking about that I mentioned
previously. So, hematopoietic tissue and bones. Hematopoietic tissue is going to be a red bone
marrow. So, the red marrow is found within the trabocular cavities of the spongy bones and the
diacoles of flat bones, such as a sternum. So, in newborns, the medullary cavities in all of the
spongy bones, they contain red bone marrow. In adults, red bone marrow, it's found in the
head of the femur. That's your upper arm bones, the humerus, and most activities,
but the most active areas of the hematopoietic are found in the flat bones,
at the diacoles of these flat bones. In addition to some of these irregular bones,
like the hip bone. This is why, again, when you need to donate a bone marrow and you go to these
donor centers, they remove it. They remove the marrow from the hip bone. A yellow marrow,
it can convert into red, if need be. So, if someone becomes anemic, for example,
the yellow marrow, it'll turn into a red marrow. So, your body, it has these backup systems in it.
Now, we're going to be talking about some of the markings that we find on bones. Remember,
this is also part of the gross anatomy, the things that you can see observed easily.
So, these markings, they're usually going to be sites where muscles come and attach to you,
or not muscles, but where you're going to find muscles that will be attaching to it,
by way of the ligaments, I'm sorry, by way of the tendons, and then also ligaments will attach
over here also, you'll find markings where ligaments attach. Now, what's the difference between the two?
The ligaments, they connect bone to bone. Okay, ligaments connect bone to bone.
Tendons, they connect a muscle to a bone. Okay, so do not forget.
Here, they're involved in joint formation, or conduits, or blood vessels, and nerves. Also,
some of them are named. So, you'll see markings over there as well. And usually these openings
are named after the blood vessels that serve them. So, not three type markings. So, first of all,
when you look at bones, and there's a big bump coming out, we call that a projection,
or a bulge of the bone. These are projections. This may be due to increased stress from muscle
pull, or as a modification for joints. Depressions, these are bulshipped, or groove-like cuts,
cutouts, that access passageways, usually for nerves or for blood vessels to go through,
or again, they could play a role in joints. Then we have the openings. Now, these openings,
or canals, in bones, they serve as passageways for, again, for nerves and for blood vessels to go through.
So, let's look at, over here. First of all, when you see a term, a tuberosity.
tuberosity is, again, by description, large, rounded projections. So, when you look over here,
what do we have here? Well, this is a tuberosity. Okay, perfect. Right over here,
this is actually a tubercle, which is a little bit different. tubercle are small,
rounded projections, and bones. Over here is good. Okay, here. So, this is a big round.
So, the part of your issue, so this is called the issue tuberosity. So, it's a large, rounded
projection, and it could be rough also. So, remember, the opposite of tuberosity is a tubercle,
where it's a small, rounded projection. Okay, and we looked at a tuberosity already.
Now, then you have something true cantra. True cantras are very large. They're blood, irregularly
shaped bumps or projections. So, right over here on your thigh bone, you have this, this is called
the greater trochanter. Okay, so it's a much higher up, and it's a big bump, so you call this
the greater. There's also lesser, this part is a lesser trochanter, because it's a little bit lower
down on this bone. Then there's lines. So, lines, these are narrow ridges of bones. They're less
prominent than a crust. Now, crust, it's a narrow ridge of the bone. So, if you look over here,
this is the iliac crust, and this is part of your hip bone. So, the upper border is called the iliac
crust. This part of the bone is called the ilium. Epic condyle, these are areas that are
that are on or above a condyle. So, when you look over here, this is the kind of the medial
condyle. So, this area above it is the, then, I'm sorry, this condyle over here, this is the medial
condyle over here. And there's also tubercle affine above it. Okay? So, it's hard to see in this
picture, but as you move along and you see close up to these bones, you'll be better able to see
these different structures, including this tubercle here, the adductor tubercle as well as the medial
abecondyle. So, remember, where we go at trochanters, lines, tubercle, epicondyle, say, epicondyle,
and then spine. So, in spine, they're sharp, they're skinning, they're slender, pointed edges.
So, when you look at this backbone, this is a spinous process over here. Okay? This is a
spine of this bone. Also, for example, you're another one that you're going to see. This is
done, is your scapula, or your shoulder blade. And then a process is just any bony prominence,
it's called referred to as a process. So, we'll see. So, the spine is processed. I'm sorry,
yeah. So, this is a bony process, spinous process. I said that incorrectly. So, spines,
so, yeah, there wouldn't be a sharp slender. So, this spinous process is not considered to be
part of a spine. So, like I said, I told you earlier, your shoulder blade, your scapula,
it has the spinous process over there. So, projections that help to form joints. So,
you have a head. So, a head is a bony expansion carried on a narrow neck. So, this is the head,
it's a bony expansion that's on the neck of this. Fast, these are smooth, nearly flat surfaces.
So, you look over here, this is very smooth, almost flat surface. Condouses are round,
rounded articulation, articulate projections. So, if you look over here,
this is your lower jaw bone, then your upper jaw bone, both of these, they come together
to form this very smooth joint. So, it's around, this is round, this is round,
articulate projection. They tend to be small. Now, rain is, that's a bar of bones, an arm
like bar of a bone. So, if you look over here, this is the rainness of your jaw. Now, grooves are
furrows. A groove is just a furrow. A fissure is a narrow slit-like opening.
And a foramen is a round oval opening that's through a bone. That's a foramen. A notch is an
indentation at the edge of a structure. That's a notch, an indentation at the edge of a structure.
So, you see a notch over here. A mead is, that's a canal, a canal-like passageway. So, your ear,
for example, the rubber here, that's a mead is. Then you assign it. So, assign it as a cavity
within a bone. Okay, it's filled with air and the sign of the mucus membrane. So, here, this is a
sign that's over here. And the fossa, okay, it's a shallow, it's a basin-like depression in a bone.
It usually serves as an articular surface, a fossa. There's a fossa over there. And again,
we'll see things in details are much closer up. It's harder to look at these, but let's just take a,
try to understand the definition at this point. So, cells of bone tissue. Now, bone tissue, bones
are made up of five major types of cells. Now, each one is specialized form of the same basic
cells type. See, osteogenic cells, osteoblasts, osteocytes, bone lining cells, and osteoclasts.
For osteogenic cells, these are also called osteoporginorator cells. And these are highly
mitotically active stem cells that we find within the periocene and the end osteome.
When these cells are stimulated, they differentiate into an osteoblast or a bone lining cell.
Some of them then remain as osteogenic stem cells now. Now, osteoblast,
these are bone-building cells, and they secrete this unmineralized bone matrix that's called an
osteoid. And this osteo is a made up of collagen and calcium binding proteins. Now,
collagen, it ends up making up 90% of the bones tissue, the protein.
Osteoblasts, these are actively mitotic also. They're very mitotic cells.
So, when you look over here, this is osteogenic stem cell. This stem cell can turn into one of
these guys, which is an osteoblasts, okay? And it, what is this? It's a matrix synthesizing cell.
That's responsible for your bone to grow. The osteocytes, these are mature bone cells that
we find within the lacunae that do not divide anymore, okay? So, they're kind of rich, you know,
the end of their reproduction time in their life cycle. And they maintain the bone matrix,
and they act as stress or strain sensors. So, they respond to mechanical stimuli,
such as an increase in force or a bone on an increase in force on bone or weightlessness.
They communicate in information to the osteoblast and as well as osteoplasts.
Osteoplasts, these are bone breaking cells. So, these are very important for bones to rebuild
themselves or bones for remodeling themselves. So, again, remember, once this, we'll talk about
it later, but remodeling is constantly occurring as well, okay? Just like buildings, for example,
you know, you take a building and after it's built, you can't just walk away from it. If you
end up doing no maintenance, you know, if you don't keep going and priming it and painting it
and maybe doing some tuck pointing, eventually that whole thing is going to become weak and,
you know, it's going to break down prematurely. Also, there's bone lining cells. Now, bone lining cells,
they're flat cells that you have on the bone surface that are believed to help maintain
the matrix along with the osteocytes. So, again, they're found on the external bone surface.
The lining cells are called the periosteal cells.
On the internal surface, they are called the endosteal cells, all right? So, remember,
the bone lining cells, depending on where they're found, they're either called periosteal cells
or endosteal cells. They're found within the internal surface, endosteal cells. If they're
found on the external surface, they're periosteal cells. Now, osteoclasts, okay? Now, these are
bone-breaking cells. They're derived from the same henotopoietic stem cells that became the
monocytes and macrophages. They're giant, multinucleated cells that function in bone
breaking or another term that we use for that is resorption, bone resorption. When these cells
are active, the cells that are located in the depressions are called resorption-based.
Now, these cells, they have these ruffled borders that serve to increase the surface area
for enzymes to start degrading the bones. Also, they help seal off areas from the surrounding matrix.
So, these are very extremely important cells. So, this is an osteocyte. This is a mature bone cell,
and this monitors and it maintains the bone matrix. Now, these osteoclasts, these are
the bone-breaking cells. Also, again, notice in the structure, they look very different. They
kind of, in somewhat, they resemble these white blood cells. But, again, notice that these are
multinucleated cells. When you look at over here, these are uni-nucleates, right? They're just one
nucleus. So, again, if you see a picture on an exam or a question, so keep in mind, to only sell
this multinucleated, when it comes to the bones, are going to be these bone-resorbing osteoclasts.
Now, compact bone, another term for compact bone, is lamellar bone. And this is made of lamellar bone
consists of this of a perversion system, okay? These are these individual bone cell units,
called the osteon. They also have canals and canaliculi in addition to that. There's this interstitial
and circumferential lamellar that they're made up of. Now, the perversion system is also called,
which is an osteon. So, this is an osteon, is a structural unit of the compact bone.
It's made up of these elongated cylinders that run parallel to the long axis of the bones,
and they act as tiny weight-bearing pillars. Now, osteon, an osteon cylinder is made up of
several rings of bone matrix. That's called the lamellar. The lamellar, they contain the collagen
fibers that run in different directions to the adjacent rings. They're able to withstand stress
and they're able to resist twisting as well. Now, bone cells are found between these collagen
fibers. So, when you look over here, these are these collagen fibers that you see, and notice,
again, the directions. They're running in opposite different directions. It's not the same. So, again,
also, then, within the central canal, it's a canal, it's an opening. You have the blood vessels and
nerves that are running through this, through them. So, again, this is what a single osteon
is made up of. Now, canals and can you look at it? So, the central canal, this hydrogen canal,
it runs through the core of this osteon. And this is where we, in the previous slide,
we saw the blood vessels and nerve endings coming out from. There's also these perforating
voguements, or they're also called vogueman canals. So, the vogueman canals, the perforating canals,
these canals, they're aligned with endostium that occurs at right angles to the central canal.
So, lacunae, these are small cavities that contain the osteocytes.
Can you look at life? These are here-like canals that connect the lacunae to one another
and to the central canal. Osteoglases secrete bone matrix, they maintain contact with one another
and the osteocytes via cell projections with gab junctions. Now, when matrix hardens and the cells
are trapped, can you look, can you look, like, are formed? Now, what this does is it allows for
communication between the osteocytes of the osteons and permit nutrients and waste to be
relayed from one cell to another cell. So, again, this is very important. This is like
the transportation system and the infrastructure of how things are able to move about.
Now, interstitial and circumferential lemmelae. Now, the interstitial lemmelae, these are
lemmelae that are not part of the osteons. Some fill gabs between forming osteons,
while others, the remnants of osteons cut by bone remodeling. Now, the circumferential lemmelae
just deep to the periosteum, but they're superficial to the end osteum. This is where they're found.
These layers of lemmelae, they extend around the entire surface of the diaphysis
and they help long bones resist twisting. In this picture here, we're going to try to connect
the dots of everything that we learned about in terms of structure so we can find these things.
So, again, what are we looking at? We're looking at a cross-section of a long bone over here.
So, this is the compact bone, the hard part of the bone, the auto part, the hard part of the bone,
and this is the spongy bone, the inner self part of the bone. This is where you have the
trabeculae that are found. This is a made up of compact bone. In other words, this has the
osteons you're going to find over here. So, when you're looking at the - before you get to that,
let's look at these. So, in osteon, it's made up of a reversion system. This is a reversion
system here. Look at all these rings. They all form a single osteon. This is another one. One,
two, three, and then you have the central canal. This is an osteon. This is another
osteon over here. From here to here is another osteon over here. So, these are all osteons
and/or reversion systems. Now, within this osteon, you have these canals. So, this is this cavity.
That's the reversion canal or the central canal. And this is what we're looking at over here.
This is a central canal. And within the central canal, you have the blood vessels that are running
through, you have your artery, a vein, as well as a nerve that run through. Now, these are running
long way. They're running longitudinally. Now, cutting off at a 90 degree angles off of these
long central - this longitudinal central canal or a seversion canal, you have these
perforating canals or these vocation canals. So, these guys, they come off and they form like
they cross through. So, think that this is like a major - think of this as like a
lateral drive, or a major expressway. And think of these as the exit points or the entrance points
or the exit points off the expressway for things to come off and to come back in from.
So, this is what these vocation canals do. Now, let's start taking a closer look at this.
Now, these are individual rings. Remember, what did we say? These are called the lamellae or the
lamellae. Now, collectively. So, when you look over here, here are all these lamellae over here,
okay? Where are you going? One, two, three, four layers of that. Then, after that, we have
this inner part. Remember what we call this? This is a central canal. Now, coming off of that,
when you look over here, these are the bone cells, the osteons. And remember what we said about the
osteons. The osteons, they lie within cavities. And what do you call those cavities? They're called
the lacuna. So, the lacuna are the cavities that hold the osteons. Now, what connects one cavity
to another cavity are these the cannuluculae, or the cannuluculae. So, lacuna are the cavities
that hold the osteons. And then, what connects one lacuna to another lacuna are these canals,
or the cannuluculae. That's how I remember it. So, these, they connect one another,
the cannuluculae. And these are these lines that you see over here, okay?
And then, again, notice this is a, you have your periosteum over here. And you can see these
sharpie fibers. And then also, you see the periosteum blood vessels. I think that's just about it
that you can see clearly over here that we covered over in the two things. Now, the interstitial
lamella and the circumferential, circumferential. They're not, I don't think they're showing,
or yeah, actually they are. So, again, it's very hard to see because they don't have a good close
up of it. But this area would be the circumferential lamella. And then, over here, this would be the
interstitial lamella. Again, it's very difficult to see because these are not ideal, optimal,
drawings to show these two structures. They did a pretty good job with other ones, but not for these.
So, now, we're going to be talking about spongy bones. So, spongy bone, it appears poorly organized,
but it's actually organized along lines of stress. And this helps the bone resist stress.
The trabeculae, they're, think of them as like cables on a bridge. And they help strengthen the
bone. They're making much, much, much stronger. So, no, we don't have any osteons that are present
in spongy bone, but the trabeculae, they do contain irregular arranged lamellae. And osteocytes that
are interconnected by this canaliculae. Capillaries in the endosium, they're what's supplying the
nutrients to the trabeculae. So, when you look over here, there you go. You got spongy bone here,
you got the compact bone, and then you have this trabeculae here of this spongy bone.
So, bone is made up of both organic and inorganic components. Now, the organic components of bones
are, they include osteogenic cells, osteoblasts, osteocytes, osteoclasts, osteoies, and the bone
lining cells. Now, osteoies, this makes up about one third of the organic bone matrix. These are
secreted by the osteoblasts. And it's made up of a grand substance of collagen fibers,
and this collagen fibers, it contributes to the high tensile strains and the flexibility of a bone.
The resilience of bone is due to the sacrificial bonds in or between the collagen molecules,
the stretch and the break to dissipate the energy and to prevent fractures from occurring.
If there's no additional trauma, the bonds they reform. Now, we're going to be talking about
the inorganic components. The inorganic components that we have are the hydroxyapatides, and these
are the mineral salts. They make up 65% of the bone mass, that's quite significant. It consists
mainly of tiny calcium physates that are in and around collagen fibers, and also the hydroxyapatite
is responsible for what hardens the bone and makes it resistant to compression.
Bone is half as strong as steel in resistant compression, but it's strong as steel in resisting
tension. It lasts long after death, because of the mineral composition. So even after you die,
for many years and years and years, you will find bone that you can find intact.
Bone also reveals a lot of information about ancient people, like what their diet was,
what type of life they lived, what type of disease they may have suffered from.
Again, they're aged at death. There's so many things you can find out when you look at bone
tissue. When we move, if you guys seek another course in anthropology, you can learn more about,
you can study this more, and then you learn about these things. This is it for the first
part of this chapter. Please leave any questions, any comments down below, in the comments below.
If you like it, please give it a thumb up, thumbs up, and please be sure to share it with your friends.
Thank you so much for watching!